We built this affiliate site in less
than 5 minutes. It's SEO and
geo-optimized.
It is conversion optimized as well to
help you earn more money and get more
clicks with your affiliate links. If you
want to see exactly how we did this,
continue watching today's video. So,
we're using Rank Site to build this
site, but we've just added in an
affiliate product integration. So, what
I'm going to do is I'm going to start by
creating a website here. I'm going to go
over to Rank Site. I'm going to create a
new site. I'm going to going to do a
general website and blog.
We're going to go to continue.
And then, I'm going to copy over this
prompt and I can pop it into my favorite
AI.
So, essentially what Claude is going to
do is it's going to go ahead and give me
the information of my business. Now, of
course, you'd want to make sure that
this is correct information
um that's relevant to your business. So,
now I'm going to paste this in here. So,
paste in the answer and hit apply. And
what's going to happen here is that it's
now going to go ahead and fill out the
information. So, it saves you a ton of
time. You can just tell the AI what you
do or or your services and then you can
copy over that information right into
Rank Site. I'm going to put a random
number in here and then you can go ahead
and go to continue. Now, if I go to
continue, as you can see, it already has
the information of my business and what
my business does. So, I can go to
continue again.
And as you can see again, it's already
included the topics that my business um
includes or my business site needs to
have and that's because it's following
the prompt that we give it. And you can
also go ahead and add more topics if you
like to do so. So, then I'm going to go
to continue.
It's chosen a color.
Right, dark premium. It's chosen the
brand color and if I have a logo, I can
go ahead and upload my logo. I'm going
to go to continue now. I'm not going to
do a form
uh for this specific website, so we're
going to skip that. And that is it.
We're good to go. We can then go ahead
and publish our site.
So, there's really no other site builder
that makes it this easy for you to
generate a site. I can literally
generate a new website in less than 1
minute. We're going to give this a
little bit of time and then we're going
to come back to see what the website
looks like.
So, our site is now live. We can go
ahead and take a look at the site. As
you can see, it looks really, really
good. We have our
um, our hero text here. We have the
information of our business. We have the
colors. Looks a really, really good um,
starting point here and we also have our
custom chatbot. We have our categories,
our about us, so on and so forth. So,
now I'm going to go over to our
dashboard.
And this is where you can then go ahead
and add in your affiliate products. So,
first I'm going to go ahead and generate
a few pages here, just making sure you
have your Open Router API key
um, connected. Then I'm going to go to
affiliate products. I'm going to enable
affiliate products. I'm going to add my
first product. So, the first product we
found here was
we'll just put the um,
Breville Plus Cooking App just as an
example.
We're actually going to upload an image
here cuz I want to see what that image
drew look would look like. We're going
to click upload.
Upload and use. And all of your images
get converted into WebP, so it allows
you to um, keep your website loading
very, very fast. We're going to place in
an affiliate link here. We can click
save.
And then we can also add in a custom
disclosure if we like to do so.
Okay, so we've generated a couple of
pages there and we've also added in our
affiliate product. Let's go ahead and
see what it looks like. We can see the
two products there. And if you head over
to resources, we can actually go ahead
and see our product here. So, we see the
product here. So, this page contains
affiliate links, and it has the link to
our product.
And of course, you can go ahead and add
as many products as you like. So, you
see the imagery, you can go ahead and
click on that link. So, your resources
will be included in your website. So, in
the resources section, you can find your
affiliate products, but if you head back
over to your dashboard, you can also
feature your affiliate products in any
of your service location or blog post
pages. So, in any of these pages, I can
click these products here to feature
these products in my actual uh page. So,
if I go to continue,
right? Then if I head over to again, if
I go to my sites, if I head over to any
of my blog posts, if I go to edit,
edit blog post,
if I scroll down here,
I can go ahead and feature my product on
these pages.
Then if I go over to back again over to
my sites, if I go over to location
pages, and I if I go over to edit, again
if I scroll down here, I can add my
products onto these pages. So, not only
are you able to add your resources,
you're also able to add any affiliate
product on any page of your website. So,
if you are an affiliate, this is going
to allow you to automate uh growing your
website as well, while also automating
uh the ability to optimize for clicks
and purchases.
So, again, not only can you create an
SEO and geo-optimized website,
everything is going to be schema marked
up, everything is going to be uh
technically SEO optimized. You can also
now add your affiliate products within
the resources or your location or blog
post pages, and then you can also set up
automations to automate generating pages
or automate generating articles on any
cadence that you like. So, if you're a
local business, or if you have a general
business, or an affiliate site, you can
now use Rank Site to generate um
affiliate sites as well for yourselves
or for your clients. Hope that you guys
enjoy today's video. We are still
running our early beta offer. It is
really, really good, discounted, and you
get hosting forever included in your
account. So, if you want to take
advantage of that, there will be a link
below. Thank you guys for watching. I'll
see you in the next one. Take care.